[Music]
there you have it Mary
that's missiles wait that's home you
stick to your rooms and your rooms only
no exploring no talking about I didn't
cause to be here
[Music]
I assure you who are you my name is Mary
Lennox and my uncle owns this house
I'm Colin Craven my cousin's you want
this house was filled with happiness now
my father wants me locked in this room
suddenly forgivable I need you to keep
secret I know a magical place where the
birds sing to you you need to see it we
could go outside who knows you might
feel better
hey are you [ __ ] hello
you know what your risk it's worth the
risk this is our garden and it can be
whatever we want
[Music]
there are even more secrets garden a
mother's made this place magical I knew
you were hiding something if you cause
me trouble and obliged by law to have
you sent to school
no need to break little Wibbly
[Music]
stay away from my son I was trying to
make expect
how's this discarded it's capable of
extraordinary things
[Music]